k
[Música]
Olá meus amigos minhas amigas como
sempre eu peço para vocês darem o
feedback de como está o áudio deve ter
um barulhinho de fundo aí que é eu tá tô
carregando aqui a bateria da moto tá
espero que não atrapalhe aí a
transmissão Boa noite Carlos Boa noite
Alexandre Isaac
Cristina Estela Mares muito obrigado por
estarem ao vivo nessa
Live nós temos algumas
perguntas para responder aqui hoje são
poucas são quatro Na verdade são cinco
não são quatro são quatro perguntas e
depois nós vamos discutir quatro artigos
aqui bem dessa vez eu vou mudar um
pouquinho aqui
ó eu vou apresentar a planilha
que é a derivada da acho que fica mais
fácil de mostrar assim mas deixa eu
aumentar aqui o tamanho para ficar mais
fácil de vocês virem verem
né Pera aí deixa eu baixar só um
pouquinho o
tamanho pera aí deixa eu ajustar isso
aqui baix
tamanho vocês estão conseguindo ver bem
aqui a a tela
is Tá difícil até de Tá T um probleminha
aqui pera
aí aqui
pronto deve tá pequeno né Deixa eu
colocar a tela inteira aqui vou vou me
tirar da tela
aqui pronto que ficar mais fácil
tá dando para ler
pessoal primeira pergunta o que que é
bom para tratamento de psoríase aí vai
depender de que você quer tratar na
medicina
Ortodoxa ou se você quer tratar na
medicina mais integrativa funcional o
tratamento mais comum para psoríase é o
uso de cremes e pomadas e
corticosteroides os famosos corticoides
aí tem betametazona dexametazona
e várias outras
né também temos os análogos da vitamina
D que é o calcipotriol o tacal citol e o
calcitriol ok também são utilizados e
tem os imun adores tópicos que é o
tacrolimus e o
pimecrolimus também tem a fototerapia
que é você fazer uso da ultravioleta
B expondo a
pele e também existe uma combinação de
ultravioleta a com o psoraleno que ativa
essa luz ultravioleta A tá seu
tratamento tópico com luz tanto a luz
direta quanto a luz associada da
psoralen medicamentos pela boca tem
vários os próprios corticoides tem os
retinoides orais tem o metotrexato que é
um imuno bloqueador aí potente tem a
ciclosporina também que é muito potente
que é usado para
transplante e tem os inibidores da pde4
que é o apremilast e tem os
imunobiológicos caríssimos aí que tem o
Ada limab o certo
lizumab E você tem também anti
interleucinas aí dentro da mé
integrativo você pode utilizar o Aloe
Vera tanto oral quanto tópico que acalma
a pele você pode usar o ômega3 em altas
doses pode usar probióticos você pode
usar
própolis e usar vitamina D em altas
doses como imunossupressor no protocolo
do do to Cícero gálio imbra eu tenho
pacientes que responderam bem a psoríase
com vitamina D em altíssimas doses no
protocolo de vitamina D como
imunossupressor e dentro as terapias
complementares você tem a acupultura
massagem yoga
Ok então São esses os tratamentos deixa
eu aqui agora reduzir de novo e
aumentar
aqui eh deixa eu fazer uma outra coisa
aqui vai fic acho vai ficar melhor
deixa eu ver se tá para ver bem
referente ao assunto dos bacteriófagos
da Live da semana passada infelizmente
não existe na manipulação Sim foi isso
que eu falei para você na
Live nem mesmo na coana eu não sei o que
que é coana é o nome de uma farmácia que
é Ah é assim que é especializada em
cepas e microrganismos
apenas os industrializados no mercado
internacional conforme comentado pelo
Senhor e pelos colegas durante a Live
como Live extension Sim sim eu comentei
isso mesmo eu comentei que só tem na
Life extension e conferi que não tem
ainda nas manipulações tá então é mais
uma observação do que uma pergunta
né D no vídeo a de segundos que eu não
sei se a médica
naturalista ou médica convencional disse
isso até pode retirar a pedra na
visícula mas não faz sentido porque uma
vez fado as pedras nós sabemos que a
vesícula é uma vesícula
doente se a gente retirar só as pedras e
manter a vesícula certamente vão formar
novas pedras e a doença vai
persistir então a gente sempre retira a
vesícula junto com as pedras você
concorda ou discorda nem uma questão de
concordar ou discordar Eliseu isso aqui
é conhecimento
comum
dentro da Medicina Tá eu vou te dar
algumas justificativas para
[Música]
isso existe sim uma situação que a gente
chama
de
Ah muito raro Tá mas existe essa
cirurgia que você só tira as pedras da
vesícula e mantém a vesícula tá que
situação que você faz
isso quando é um paciente muito idoso e
muito debilitado e que a cirurgia tem
que ser extremamente rápida Então é só
essa situação que realmente se justifica
fazer a celit tomia celit tomia seria a
retirada das Pedras da vesícula Ok então
se você mantém a vesícula tem alguns
estudos teve um estudo com 178 pacientes
em que 24% dos que mantiveram a vesícula
apresentaram novos eventos biliares tá
24% é um número bem razoável isso
incluiu colangite que é uma complicação
rara que é uma infecção do sistema
biliar 13 casos de colangite cinco casos
de colecistite aguda que é infecção da
vesícula biliar dois casos de dor biliar
e um caso decí
tá então nudo de 178 pacientes 24%
complicaram quando mantiveram a
vesícula Então pode acontecer o
derramamento de B na cavidade abdominal
quando você mantém a vesícula quando ela
tá doente pode dar peritonite pode dar
colecistite pode dar colangite pode
formar abscesso e até pancreatite biliar
em 0,4 por dos casos
tá Então na verdade o que ela falou tá
correto tá isso é um
conhecimento padrão dentro da Medicina
agora o que tem que ser discutido é todo
mundo que tem pedra na vesícula deve
operar vesícula essa que é a pergunta
mais correta tá e a minha visão sobre
isso que não você só deve operar
vesícula se tiver sintomas
significativos ou se tiver algum tipo de
complicação
então se tiver dor frequente ou se tiver
tido alguma evidência de que infeccionou
a vesícula deu uma
colecistite aí nesses casos é melhor
operar agora paciente assintomático
Geralmente eu tento 90 dias de uso do
ácido uso deoxicólico
que pode ajudar a eliminar essas pedras
o protocolo
do detox pato biliar eu não confio não
tá para ser bem sincero aquele tox
do Andreas Andreas fugiu o nome agora
mas é o detox pato biliar aquilo lá não
confio vamos pra próxima
pergunta deixa aumentar aqui de novo a
tela uso de psicoestimulante sendo uma
droga pode levar o efeito de tolerância
e perda de efeito ao longo prazo no TDH
quais principais mudanças na sua visão
para conseguir ter isso Estela Andrés
murit me deu um branco aqui mas é o esse
daí então voltando aqui o uso de
psicoestimulantes sendo uma droga pode
levar o efeito de tolerância e perda de
efeito ao longo prazo do TDH quais
principais mudanças na sua visão para
conseguir ter um bom
rend bem sim existe um ris de
dependência existe um risco da pessoa ir
aumentando a dose cada vez mais
especialmente com venvance isso levar a
tolerância e dependência e a pessoa
ficar viciada tá agora se você usar
doses baixas de venvance e
associar com tratamentos naturais e com
mudança estilo de vida o risco de
dependência pode ser até baixo vai
depender muito de como é conduzido esse
caso
então não deve aumentar a dose demais
não deve dar dose excessiva o venvance é
muito parecido com cocaína na Química
dela então a gente tem que tomar muito
cuidado Então quais são os hitos
fundamentais que a gente deve fazer para
poder melhorar esse ddh repor o magnésio
uso da LT anina praticar exercícios
físicos regularmente para aliviar o
estresse melhorar o humor tem uma boa
qualidade de sono alimentar com
alimentos não inflamatórios portant os
processados ultraprocessados açúcar né
isso que vocês estão cansados de escutar
que eu falando
né criar um sistema de organização com
agenda em lembretes então quanto mais
organizado Mas você utilizar sistemas
informatizados ou agendas bem
organizadas vai ser mais
fácil definir prioridades e começar
pelas tarefas mais importantes realizar
uma tarefa de cada vez não tendo essa
questão do multitarefa que é um engano é
Umo dividir Grandes projetos em partes
menores estabelecer horários fixos para
verificar e-mails para não ficar
distraído Ok e outros tipos de redes
sociais e outras comunicações
manter o ambiente do trabalho organizado
livre de distrações
utilizar técnica de pomodoro né que é
uma técnica muito interessante para
alternar períodos de concentração com
pausas documentar a rotina manter uma
agenda com horários e
compromissos fazer tratamento cognitivo
comportamental Importante que pode
ajudar a desenvolver estratégias de
enfrentamento e modificar
comportamentos Beleza então essas que
são as dicas aí usar doses baixas dos
estimulantes usar Magnésio e LT anina
são os principais aí e essas medidas que
eu acabei de falar vocês podem voltar o
vídeo se caso tenha falado muito
rápido bem vamos voltar aqui eu acho que
foi a última essa aqui viu foi a
última Se tiverem aí obrigado pelo
feedback do som
Cristina tiverem mais perguntas ao vivo
podem colocar aqui tá no bate-papo do
YouTube bem vamos falar dos artigos aqui
deixa eu mudar a tela de novo
Ok então o primeiro artigo que queria
discutir com vocês é um treinamento
interessante de caminhada
intervalada que foi descoberto no Japão
que é um excelente método de melhorar a
pressão
arterial então é uma maneira fácil
eficaz acessível de melhorar a saúde
melhorar a pressão arterial é um
condicionamento fisco acessível a todos
nós mesmo aqueles que TM restrição aí
que não pode correr e é bem simples vão
entender que é bem tranquilo e japoneses
constataram que ele é bem poderoso para
transformar rotina diária de pessoas aí
que são
sedentárias então o treinamento de
caminhada intervalada que foi
desenvolvido por pesquisadores japoneses
é um método que combina período de
caminhada lenta e relaxada com rajadas
curtas de passos rápidos intensos é
quase é praticamente igual tá aquele Hit
né High intensity
interval Training só que a diferença
aqui é que é o hit leve ou seja você não
fica alternando entre andar e correr
você fica alternando entre andar e andar
mais rápido então um andar leve relaxado
alternado com o andar eh quase correndo
tá aquele andar assim de marcha atlética
né então é interessante porque pega leve
nas articulações
e leva benefício paraa saúde Então esse
sistema né de caminhada intervalada ele
alterna entre 3 minutos de caminhada
lenta e 3 minutos de caminhada rápida
então como eu disse é muito acessível
muito simples e o estudos mostram que
ela pode reduzir a pressão arterial
sistólica quatro vezes mais do que
caminhar 10.000 Passos por dia então eu
sempre oriento os pacientes a caminhar
8.000 Passos por dia porque tá dizendo
que essa técnica aqui de você alternar
intensidade é quatro vezes mais potente
para baixar a pressão arterial sistólica
do que você só andar de qualquer jeito e
a também através dessas informações
japoneses segundo eles diminui o risco
de ter Rame né de AVC em 40% em 5 anos e
reduz sintomas de depressão em 50% e
melhora a qualidade do sono em 12% Então
melhora depressão
sono reduz derrame e reduz pressão
arterial um dos participantes do estudo
comentou que costumava ficar doente o
tempo todo mas depois que começou a
fazer essa caminhada intervalada passou
a se sentir mais forte e raramente fica
gripado
então tem essa evidência de que
exercícios de caminhadas intervaladas
podem fortalecer o sistema imune e
aumentar a produção de células de
defesa também existe a informação de que
fortalece os músculos isquiotibiais são
os músculos lá que juntam
né o quadril a coxa e melhora a
resistência geral
então dicas Caso vocês queiram
experimentar primeiro faz um alongamento
para evitar lesões comece com uma
caminhada lenta com passos curtos por 3
minutos então deve ser uma caminhada
leve o suficiente para você poder
conversar confortavelmente ok Aí você
passa mais 3 minutos de caminhada rápida
aí você vai fazer um passo bem mais
largo né deixando os calcanhares tocarem
o chão primeiro primeiro calcanhar
depois a ponta do pé e balança os braços
para ganhar impulso então é aquela
aquele andar assim bem amplo né o passo
Bem largo e bem rápido
Ok praticamente aquela marcha atlética
né você vê que a marcha atlética eles
fazem uns passos mais curtos né se eu
não me engano mas aqui no caso o passo é
largo Então você vai repetir o ciclo por
minutos três caminhada leve três
caminhada rápida ou divid sessões
menores se você tiver com menos condição
física Então tem que ser consistente tem
que fazer pelo menos 60 minutos por
semana eu até Faria 30 minutos
diário mas para quem tá começando pode
começar com 10 minutos por
dia e se você puder arrume um parceiro
ou parceira de caminhada isso ajuda
muito a manter né a a rotina a
disciplina e se você puder fazer bem ao
ar livre em trilhas na natureza melhor
ainda mas se não puder faz um parque
mesmo pé da sua casa ou mesmo na rua
né Então lembre-se dessa história aí da
caminhada intervalada né o treino de
caminhada
intervalada Como eu disse é quase um Hit
isso aqui é um Hit com caminhada sem
corrida meem o próximo tem vai ser
discutido é sobre disne epidemia então
eu recebi por e-mail um
artigo da sociedade internacional de
orto molecular que eu achei muito
interessante quis discutir com vocês
aqui esse artigo vocês sabem que por
muitos anos né Por décadas já
praticamente há 50 anos o colesterol foi
sempre o foco principal no manejo da
doença cardiovascular
aterosclerótica Mas será que ele é esse
vilão mesmo esse será que ele é a causa
Raiz Esse é uma pergunta que o pessoal
da Medicina funcional sempre faz e esta
confusão é muito grande né os
cardiologistas são extremamente
eh ensinados né
extremamente como é que é o
termo até lavagem cerebral né ele sofrem
para você realmente ter um uma ênfase
muito grande na
estatina só que tem vários estudos aí
que sugerem que não é o principal fator
o colesterol Então nós vamos discutir
esses fatores
agora então o entendimento da Medicina
funcional que a dislipidemia não é a
causa raiz da doença cardiovascular ou
aterosclerótica ela é apenas uma parte
do quebra-cabeça abordagem que vocês
conhecem que é centrada no colesterol
ele ignora outras questões mais
complexas e profundas então nós temos aí
no meio da confusão aí que devemos levar
em consideração hábitos alimentares
desequilíbrios hormonais especialmente
da tireoide e também do stradi nas
mulheres e fatores de estilo de
vida então o ponto que a gente vai
comear a discutir aqui são as dietas
ricas em carboidratos os carboidratos
refinados a gente sabe muito bem eles
levam a aumento dos triglicérides porque
eles são convertidos dentro do fígado de
carboidrato a gordura a triglicérides e
também leva a redução do HDL colesterol
que você sabe que é o chamado colesterol
bom então existe uma confusão muito
grande Inclusive eu vou falar de um
estudo que discute um pouco esse assunto
em seguida um estudo até
que paradoxalmente fala contra esta
ideia de que eu vou falar agora que as
dietas cetogênicas e de baixo
carboidrato é um são promissoras para
baixar tré a metal HD colesterol Então
não é todo mundo que concorda com isso
mas eu tendo a acreditar nessa visão de
que a dieta queto rica em vegetais é
muito bom para controlar os lipídeos do
sangue e baixar peso eolar glicose
também então essa dieta quet bem feita
né sem exagero de gordura saturada vai
melhorar os perfis lipídicos vai reduzir
o risco cardiovascular
Então os alimentos mais graves mais
problemáticos são os
ultraprocessados são também os óleos de
semente com ômega-6 em exagero né o caso
do óo de soja milho canola e girassol E
também o charope de milho de alta
frutose que tá presente nos doces nos
pães e alimentos processados todos esses
causam um grande impacto no metabolismo
dos das gorduras isso vai alimentar
inflamações e estress
oxidativo outra causa são as
deficiências de micronutrientes
principalmente a deficiência de vitamina
B de bola 3 an niacina do ácido
pantotênico que é o B5 e a B6 também a
vitamina C tem um prot tem um fator
protetor contra a TR esclerose
especialmente pelo a pela ação
antioxidante a vitamina D de dado também
tem correlação com a dislipidemia quanto
mais baixa a vitamina D mais risco de
dislipidemia e os tocotrienois da
família aí da vitamina E também tem
efeito de baixar as gorduras do sangue
também temos o mineral magnésio muito
importante pro metabolismo lipídico
Então vocês tem que garantir que as
vitaminas do complexo B especialmente B3
B5 B6 a vitamina C A vitamina D e tocot
trenois sejam em níveis
adequados a vitamina C não apenas reduz
o LDL colesterol mas também Combate o
press oxidativo por ser o antioxidante e
da mesma forma o magnésio ajuda a
aumentar os níveis de HDL colesterol e
melhorar o perfil
lipídico outra questão que quase ninguém
Lembra pelo menos dos meios leigos é que
existe infecções
crônicas que podem piorar a saúde da
parede da artéria levando a artéria
esclerose Então tem que ter muito
cuidado com a saúde dental porque a
periodontite tem infecção que acontece
entorno dos dentes né no tecido mole
entorno dos dentes e infecções virais
podem desregular os níveis lipídicos e
aumentar risco cardiovasculares então é
importante sempre investigar a boca
escovar bem os dentes passar fio dental
tomar cuidado para não ter uso de
produtos que pior microbioma oral que é
o caso por exemplo dos colutórios aí de
coline então utilizar óleo de coco
utizar
colutórios naturais em vez de utilizar
esses enxaguantes urais aí que
atrapalham microbioma e tratar as
infecções crônicas ajudam a melhorar os
pref lipídicos a Inatividade física é um
fator muito importante porque a falta
dessa atividade ela vai baixar o HDL
aumentar triglicérides Então tem que
fazer atividade física tanto para mentar
HDL quanto para reduzir os
triglicérides isso vai bater des
lipidemia tá exercícios moderados já t
esse efeito de melhor perfil lipídico e
também presta atenção nos desequilíbrios
hormonais se tiver com hipotiroidismo é
muito importante tratar porque o
hipotiroidismo aumenta o colesterol
aumenta o LDL colesterol e baixa o HDL e
a deficiência de estrogênio nas mulheres
que têm indicação de utilizar a
reposição hormonal porque quando você
tem a deficiência de estrogênio não
tratada eh durante a menopausa isso
também aumenta esses níveis de
colesterol se essa mulher não tiver
indicação de repor não deve repor mas
sempre que for possível usar o
estrogênio bioidêntico ISO molecular
isso vai ajudar bastante a a controlar a
dislipidemia então é importante lembrar
desses fatores a dislipidemia é uma
condição complexa não é a única coisa aí
que vai afetar a saúde arterial esta
também é um marcador importante como já
falei manter a saúde hormonal ficar
longe de infecções então também os
marcadores de informação crônica podem
ajudar bastante então ficar atento a
proteína ser reativa ao VHS tá
aumentado e ficar atento aos níveis de
vitaminas a b c d e e Ok na verdade b c
d e e e o magnésio são os principais
próximo artigo É sobre o papel da dieta
cetogênica e o impacto dela no controle
do açúcar aqui nós estamos falando do
açúcar e não do colesterol em pessoas
que já tem diagnóstico tipo do existe
uma discussão na literatura se de fato a
dieta
cetogênica ela é mais potente ou não do
que uma dieta que não seja muito baixo
em carboidrato para controle glicêmico
porque às vezes eles
questionam que a dieta cetogênica
poderia estar funcionando
através simplesmente da perda de peso e
não simplesmente porque tá restringindo
carboidrato eu acho tanto quanto
estranho isso mas eu quero mostrar para
vocês outro lado pra gente poder ter a
cabeça sempre aberta pra ciência mesmo
que a ciência a gente não Concorde
tá então eu acredito e você
provavelmente já escutou que a dieta
cetogênica ela pode ser um game changer
para gerenciar os níveis de açúcar no
sangue porém muitas literaturas médicas
aí questionam
isso então fizeram uma pesquisa de por
10 dias de duração em que deram os
alimentos para as pessoas nesses 10 dias
e houve uma troca né ou seja as pessoas
comeram uma dieta por 5 dias depois
comeram outra dieta por 5 dias
essa pesquisa ela envolveu 29 adultos no
Texas a idades eram entre 18 e 70 anos
todos tinham diabetes tipo do E
sobrepeso então esse grupo foi diverso e
proporcionou alguns insights como
diferentes abordagens alimentares
poderiam afetar o controle do açúcar
Então os pesquisadores realizaram ensaio
randomizado
cruzado de 10 dias como eu falei os
participantes seguiram três intervenções
dietéticas uma dieta padrão uma dieta
cetogênica e uma dieta cetogênica
complementada com cetonas né com Bet
hidróxico tiado então de maneira
simplificada cada participante
experimentou cada dieta em uma ordem
randomizada permitindo uma comparação
direta de seus efeitos então todos os
participantes 29 usaram as três dietas
nesse período de 10 dias então não foram
cinco dias foram 2 dias e meio né para
cada
dieta ou TRS dias né não TRS dias e na
verdade TRS Dias E3 né não sei como é
que eles fizeram para dividir 10 dias em
três mas foi esse o informação que eles
estão falando aqui então segundo Esse
estudo não houve diferenças
significativas no controle glicêmico
entre a dieta padrão e as dietas
cetogênicas quando o peso foi
mantido então
eles acreditam que a dieta com mais
carboidrato cont tanto que a pessoa
perdeu peso igual a dieta cetogênica Dá
no mesmo eu não concordo com isso OK mas
é o que pareceu no
estudo porém eles admitiram que houve
mudanças específicas nos níveis de
insulina e glicose que foi mais baixo
nos que tavam fazendo no período da
dieta cetogênica
então o estudo termina falando que
existem metanálises anteriores que
corroboram que dietas de baixo
carboidrato poderiam melhorar o controle
glicêmico porém se você perder peso o
suficiente com uma dieta que não seja
necessariamente baixa em carboidrato
daria no mesmo
Ok só que esse estudo em questão ele
teve uma duração muito cur né 10 dias
apesar de ter sido estudo muito rigoroso
que as pessoas comeram somente aquela
aqueles
alimentos fornecido pelos
pesquisadores então muitas vezes
adaptações metabólicas a restrição de
carboidratos podem levar mais tempo para
manifestar então o ideal seria pelo
menos 30 dias de estudo só que se fica
muito caro quando você fornece os
alimentos e tem que ficar no pé das
pessoas para comer só os alimentos que
são fornecidos aí pelos pesquisadores
eles admitem que o tipo de gordura
consumido na
dieta no caso ketogenica pode ter
influenciado os
resultados então concluindo embora as
dietas cetogênicas possam ser eficazes
para gerenciar o diabetes tipo 2
Especialmente quando se trata de perde
de peso Esse estudo sugere que seus
benefícios podem não ser exclusivamente
devido a restrição de carboidratos
parece que as respostas individuais
podem variar e o que funciona para uma
pessoa pode não funcionar paraa outra eu
particularmente acho que as pessoas
devem fazer cetogênica e só não devem
fazer pelo menos por 90 dias a pessoa
tiver muita resistência ou passar muito
mal ou ficar muito mal com essa dieta
porque para iniciar
um uma melhora no diabetes 90 dias de
cetogênica eu acho muito interessante
não que a pessoa vai ficar o resto da
vida na cetogênica mas depois ela pode
passar por uma low carb tirando todos os
carboidratos
refinados é importante a gente encontrar
um padrão alimentar que se ajuste Ao
estilo de vida de cada
pessoa bem vamos ver se nós temos
comentários ao vivos Ó tem sim tem
perguntas aqui Eliseu chegou já chegou
com a sua metralhadora giratória de
perguntas
melatonina Slow release tem liberação
prolongada mesmo sendo sublingual Não aí
não faria sentido né Aí você teria que
tomar via oral porque não tem como você
fazer uma coisa sublingual ser de
liberação prolongada tá isso é
impossível
eh por si só né é uma impossibilidade
física isso daí
Eliseu tem que est escrito que a
melatonina é de liberação lenta né Slow
release ou liberação lenta liberação
prolongada faz mal tomar banho depois de
almoçar ouv dizer que passar sabonete na
barriga atrapalha a circulação de
sangue se tiver comido muito faz mal tá
Se tiver com muito cheio faz mal sim eu
eu faria um intervalo de pelo menos uma
hora se a pessoa comeu muito tá Du horas
na verdade você pessoa comu
muito talher de silicone liberam
toxinas talher de silicone eu nunca vi
isso
Eliseu não sei te dizer mas silicone é
um material mole né Eu nunca vi esse
esse talé de silicone a princípio não
mas eu realmente eu nunca vi na prática
para ter
certeza frango assado na orgânico e a
carne que tem mais
agrotóxico remédio e hormônio é o que
tem mais hormônio tá
agrotóxico depende né geralmente pode
ter bastante agrotox sim nos cereais que
eles comem especialmente o milho né mas
E no caso do Chester é a mesma coisa se
o Chester foi criado em sistema de
confinamento sim é bem
parecido num vídeo feito há um ano você
disse que o óleo de COC nativo não não
falei isso isso é informação do Lair
Ribeiro tá eu eu simplesmente repliquei
essa informação mas eu acho a informação
muito complicada tá isso significa que o
óleo de coco impede que o HIV evolua
para a eu não posso afirmar isso Eliseu
eu não confiaria
nisso diarreia cendo sangue pode ser
consequência da retirada da vesícula não
não conheço essa complicação de colest
tomia um vídeo seu no YouTube contei um
rapaz ensinando a fazer cal de osso Esse
vídeo é um vídeo que eu tirei de um
outro canal tá se os ossos forem de
ossos de frango esses ossos também terão
agrotóxicos sim vão ter vão ter
sim após remover a pedra da vesícula sem
retirar vesícula isso não vai acontecer
eles como eu expliquei tá eles só não
tiram a vesícula em casos muito
especiais gente muito idosa que tá
realmente com muita fragilidade tá então
isso na prática não vai acontecer je
você tá falando
aqui é porque não vai acontecer ela ela
send jovem eles não vão aceitar tirar
suas pedras tá não Não conheço nenhum
médico que vai aceitar só remover a
pedra
visí Boa noite
Vanete tem alguma coisa natural bom para
evitar ân de
vômito natural
geralmente quando eu passo antiemético
eu não passo natural não eu passo
remédio mesmo tá o danron que é o zofran
ou out tem outras marcas aí tá então
natural ag de cabeça não tô lembrando de
nenhum tá Manuel posso dar uma olhada
aqui porque geralmente a gente não passa
natural não da Ana de
vômito Verê se eu acho alguma coisa
aqui nunca passei tô sendo bem franco
com vocês aqui natural não para isso
não
ah o gengibre ele pode ajudar paraa
náusea tá gengibre então você pode fazer
um fazinho de gengibre se análoga não
for muito
forte existe também gengibre
cristalizada eu já até comi isso daqui
não me lembrava que isso aqui tinha
efeito antin náusea você pode usar
também o óleo de pepermint né óleo
essencial o pé permite é ort lã pimenta
tem também a ação de reduzir
náusea aromaterapia com limão capim
capim limão também
ajuda o próprio o óleo essencial de
gengibre chá de camomila pode ajudar e
chá também de alcaçus pode ajudar tá bom
são essas substâncias
naturais Boa noite Dr Ana
Paula aí ó que a Dora tá falando É muito
raro remover somente as pedras são
naquela situação que eu falei de
pacientes idosos e que estão muito
frágeis
emites aqui ó ela falando óleo essencial
zengest que tem com certeza esse óleo
tem também o gengibre tá é uma mistura
de
óleos fale sobre diarreia após atirado
de vesícula sim sim existe uma situação
quando a pessoa tira a vesícula como ela
não tem mais o o órgão para armazenar o
suco bilhar concentrado que vai ser
utilizado durante a refeição então Eh o
fígado fica jogando o líquido biliar né
o suco biliar o tempo todo no
Delgado tá E no duodeno e não tem onde
armazenar então a pessoa por exemplo
pode comer muita gordura na refeição e
não vai ter sais biliares para
emulsificar a gordura e o que que
acontece essa pessoa pode ter diarreia
do tipo gordurosa que é esteatorreia tá
então isso é muito comum como
complicação de operação de vesícula
biliar E aí algs casos você tem que usar
realmente sais biliares na refeição e
enzimas para ajudar a quebrar a gordura
Ok dieta cetogênica implica
necessariamente em perda de peso É
difícil fazer uma dieta cetogênica sem
perder peso Isaac A não ser que você já
esteja magro e você na dieta cetogênica
você você engira uma quantidade de
proteína bem significativa que não tire
você da acetose Mas é bem difícil
geralmente quando você faz cetogênica
você perde nem que seja uns 3 kg
tá não é mortiz é morit
Eliseu já mostrei isso aqui em live
anterior pode fazer inalação com óleos
essenciais para
bronquite inalação não mas você pode
porque o óleo essencial ele é muito
potente você colocar el direto no
inalador eu acho que vai irritar a
mucosa Eh mas você pode colocar ele no
difusor tá eu não conheço essa aplicação
de óleo essencial colocado diretamente
num difusor tá ou inalador desculpa
difusor não inalador difusor sem
inalador Eu não colocaria eu acho que
ele é muito concentrado pode dar
problema não conheço pelo menos se tiver
essa essa forma de utilizar deve ser bem
diluído Você conhece Ana Paula tá
acompanhando Você conhece aí
o uso de óleo essencial direto no
inalador esperar um pouquinho
aqui bem eu vou ficar até uma hora tá ou
seja são
7:48 tem 41 minutos de
Live vou ficar no máximo até 60 minutos
mas eu vou aguardar vocês se
manifestarem no caso na Paula se tiver
acompanhando
agora aí uma saudação da Estela Mares
paraa Dra Ana
Sim sim eu falei isso eliz eu não
acredito no protocolo morit não não que
eu não acredite eu não acredito nele
para eliminar pedra eu até acredito nele
como uma maneira de fazer detox mas não
para eliminar Pedra da da visícula ou do
sistema biliar tá realmente e e é uma
falta veja bem não quer dizer que eu sou
contra quem faça que vou que eu vou sair
no no pau aí com alguém que que promove
o protocolo do murit jeito nenhum vou
ficar na minha não vou me manifestar
contra de jeito
nenhum mas baseado em tudo que eu
vi eu não acredito nele não para
objetivo de eliminar cálculos biliares
não agora para detox Ele até funciona
assim eu conheço vários passos que
fizeram e que se sentiram bem então eu
não discuto eh se sente bem
eh faz o detox né mas não a que a pessoa
vai eliminar pedra com isso daí tá o que
sai nas fezes tem um estudo antigo que
que mostrou que é o que sai nas fezes é
a
agregação do azeite de oliva que é
tomado mais o o magnésio que é tomado Tá
então não é pedra que tá saindo ali da
da vesícula ou do sistema biliar Mas se
vocês quiserem acreditar também não tem
problema tá se vocês quiserem acreditar
no protocolo morit não é aqui paraa
gente entrar em discussões acaloradas ou
apaixonadas
táa Paula acho que ela não tá mais ao
vivo não então tá dormindo não sei ou tá
dirigindo não
sei então a única saída para essa pessoa
que falei realmente mover a vesícula ou
se ela tiver sintomática ou com
complicações sim Eliseu agora se ela tá
totalmente assintomática ela pode
simplesmente não operar veículo tá tem
que ver Sea pedra é pequena Sea pedra é
grande se a pedra tá entupindo em
infundíbulo da vesícula se tem risco de
col Cistite se tem risco de colangite se
tem risco de da pedra entrar no coled
com entupida na pancreatite então é tem
vários detalhezinhos aí dizer tá Mas
grosseiramente falando se a pessoa tiver
assintomática e o cálculo não for capaz
de entupir o infundíbulo da vesícula ou
coled pode simplesmente não operar
tá aqui o depoimento da Ivanete ou
Evanete desculpa Doutora já fiz esse
protocolo
boara boara Dev ser para né remoção de
pedra na vesícula melhorou muito o meu
refluxo sim é um detox é um detox né
porque como eu falei muita gente sente
bem com esse detox só Não esperem que a
pedra vesícula vai sair porque eu test
tem quatro ou cinco pacientes e não saiu
tá não saiu a pedra
visí você indica o médico para avaliar a
situação dessa
pessoa é eu trabalho com sim pode mandar
para mim né ou pode passar aí com gastro
funcional tipo Carvalho tipo a d
Lívia tipo A Den Carvalho nem tá
atendendo paciente novo né mas pode ser
aquela Dra Lívia não me lembro sobrenome
dela ou Dr rud Ramos Deixa eu ver se eu
consigo descobrir aqui o sobrenome da
Lívia dout Lívia
é Lívia Guimarães Lívia Guimarães tá tem
essa Dora Lívia Guimarães aí e o Dr rud
Ramos não é rud ramos não pessoal
desculpa é Dr Cristiano rud Cristiano
rud rud Ramos é um bairro de São
Bernardo
e que mais pessoal
para jovens na faixa de 25 anos mais ou
menos quanto seria ideal ou máximo de
DHT para não sofrer a efeitos deletérios
de queda e oleosidade capilar eu
manteria esse DHT no segundo quartil tá
eí laboratório para laboratório isso
varia então uma teria ele em torno do
quartil ou seja menos da metade para
cima tá Seria um número aí mais seguro
para não acontecer aí problema de queda
de cabelo e aumento de
próstata de quanto em quanto tempo uma
pessoa deve fazer um
aterramento não ten essa informação para
te dar Manuel faa o máximo que puder tá
se você puder fazer uma vez por semana
você faz se você tiver o tapetinho de
aterramento em casa faz umas três vezes
por
semana ou se você tem aí o privilégio de
morar perto de um parque ou num Bosque
ou de praia
faça quanto mais fizer melhor Tá quanto
mais fizer melhor mas eu nas minhas
leituras Eu não busquei assim essa
informação tão Clara assim que tem que
fazer x vezes quanto mais você fizer
melhor
tá não tem contraindicação para
aterramento Só não vai fazer fio terra
tá desculpa não aguentei de fazer essa
piada piada besta eh it perfeito Doutor
gratidão de nada itac Desculpe a piada
grosseira pessoal eh
[Música]
falta 5 minutos para as 8
horas Obrigado Eliseu aí pela gentileza
Tá mas é assim Eliseu não vai ter jeito
tá você não vai encontrar um um
cirurgião na terra que vai querer fazer
essa cirurgia sem tirar vesículo tá eu
acho que só vi duas vezes na minha vida
fazerem col elit tomia ou seja tirar só
as pedras e manter visí
eh Fi na residência de cirurgia geral
que eu vi isso mas eram pacientes muito
graves tá pacientes que tava só o pó da
rabiola e até um de vocês morreram
depois então não é uma situação na
prática você
vai ver isso daí tá
bom D Ana paula d Ana Paula você não tá
mais se manifestando acho que você não
está acompanhando a
Live mais perguntas pessoal
Estela Mares meu sogro fez Pois foi pós
trombose
mesentérica mas depois teve que retirar
visícula tá vendo interessante ela fez
então ele fez a retirada só das Pedras
porque era idoso e também tava num
quadro de trombose ou seja el tava numa
situação
grave então por isso que só tiraram as
pedras mas mesmo assim deu uma melhorada
Tiraram a visícula tá vendo aqui ó na
prática aqui para vocês verem depoimento
da
Estela sim é verdade Carlos pode tá
maior bagunça dentro da da
vesícula eu quando tava na residência de
cirurgia geral a gente via vesículas
assim muito muito inflamadas a gente
tirava as pedras e via que a vesícula
algumas vezes estava até endurecida
queela vesícula em porcelana em alguns
casos também a vesícula tava cheia de
pus não tinha nem como pensar
em D Ana Paula atende pacientes de
lipedema atende sim tá eu sei que você
dirigiu a ela a pergunta mas ela não tá
ligada eu acho que ela não tá
acompanhando agora não
bem provável o conteúdo totalmente
degradado da visícula sim é verdade
Carlos não Eliseu é isso Pelo que eu
entendi da que Estela tá falando é que
eles já programaram isso tiraram o cara
da urgência porque ele tava com trombose
mesentérica e tava com as pedras na
vesícula lá entupindo na vesícula aar
Eli da urgência e assim que ele melhorou
Eles já programaram isso para retirar a
visícula não quiseram nem
eh experimentar mudança estilo de vida
não
viu
H na época O médico disse que coria
corria risco de morrer na época do quê
da retirada da pedra só da colit notomia
é isso tá falando
E aí por isso que não retiraram a
visícula no primeiro momento né É isso
que tá querendo dizer né só para
confirmar Estela
Ok Estela você quer entrar comigo ao
vivo Estela para contar essa história
melhor quer entrar te mando o
link porque tá eu tô entendendo você tá
querendo
dizer E que o seu sogro corria risco de
morrer por isso só tiraram as pedras no
primeiro momento e depois fizeram a
retirada da visícula
faz de pijama tá
bom P vai vai aumentar vai falar vai
aumentar a audiência da
Live tá morrer na mesa de cirurgia
mesmo tá mas morrer na mesa cirurgia da
primeira cirurgia querendo dizer isso ou
da segunda
cirurgia então deixa Dea eu tô
entendendo ela tá dizendo que a foi
optado pela retirada só das Pedras da
vesícula e não do órgão inteiro devido
ao risco de morrer na cirurgia isso que
eu tava falando antes por isso que em
alguns casos raríssimos não se tira
vesícula Tira só as pedras porque a
pessoa tá correndo risco de vida não é
isso ele tinha acabado de retirar o
intestino AEC sim por causa da trombose
mesentérica né e teve o problema na
visícula não acho que ficou Claro sim
tá não Eliseu não provoca não deixa ela
quietinha lá
tá deixou ela quietinha lá
bem pessoal
eh Muito obrigado aí pela presença de
vocês eu acho que eu vou encerrar a Live
A não ser que já já não tenha mais
perguntas agora com essa história aí do
pijama eu lembrei daqueles vídeos do
YouTube né que o pessoal coloca assim o
fil não tem nada a ver com o vídeo né
coloca aqueles fil lá que cenas assim
digamos assim provocantes no fil e o
pessoal vai abrir o vídeo não tem nada
daquilo lá no vídeo né lembrei disso daí
né mas é isso
aí bem eu acho que é isso né pessoal
obrigado pela presença de vocês e a
gente se vê na semana que vem tá
bom abraço beijo no
coração desculpa as brincadeira viu
ST n